Das ist wirklich nicht gut auf der internationalen raumstation iss gab es offensichtlich einen
sabotageakt das liegt das letzte woche aufgetaucht ist wurde nicht durch einen materialfehler oder ein stark eines
meteoriten verursacht sondern durch ein von einem menschen gebohrtes loch
wie bitte was ist passiert und was sind jetzt vor allem die konsequenzen klick zum zeitpunkt schon herzlich willkommen
Gar nicht gut gar nicht gut was ist da oben los und das schlimme scheinbar scheint es keiner so richtig zu wissen die fakten
vergangene woche donnerstag wurde ein leck in der raumstation iss
festgestellt stück für stück wurden die shots der module geschlossen um den ort der undichtigkeit
einzugrenzen schließlich stieß die besatzung auf ein loch in einer angedockten
sojus-kapsel und zwar genau der mit der alexander gerst am 6 juni zur iss gestartet war die suris
ms09 erst wurde ein produktionsfehler ein metroid oder einriss vermutet noch was jetzt öffentlich wurde
lässt einem das blut in den adern gefrieren und das ist absolut keine übertreibung ein ehemaliger
kosmonaut hat sich dazu jetzt zu wort gemeldet maxim surajew
äußert die sehr beunruhigende vermutung dass ein besatzungsmitglied je sabotiert hat der staatlichen nachrichtenagentur
ria nowosti sagte er dass es nicht ausgeschlossen werden könne dass ein besatzungsmitglied
zitat diese seltsame nummer abgezogen hat wir sind alle menschen und jeder könnte nach hause wollen
die nasa hat die aufnahme des lochs inzwischen aus dem netz genommen
wohl weil sie ziemlich erschreckend ist wie haben sie aus dem netz gefischt und
können hier die wirklich schlimmen details zeigen man sie deutlich dass bei der sabotage mehrfach versucht wurde
anzusetzen der bohrer ist mehrere male abgerutscht bevor dann griff und das loch bohrt
die besatzung fand das loch letzte woche und konnte mit epoxidharz und einem tuch flicken
was kosmos direktor dmitri rogozin wurde erst in mailand und missstände beim sojus programm zu beseitigen
jetzt ist es noch schlimmer diese sabotage macht raumfahrt hinzu kunst extrem unsicher die frage ist immer noch wer
konkret hat das getan die spekulationen schießen in den letzten stunden ins kraut raumfahrt journalist eric berger meint zu wissen
dass es indizien gebe dass der schaden bereits auf der erde entstand er behauptet dass ein techniker
diesen bohr fehler sei mit leim verschloss wodurch ihr baywa kommt es nicht auffiel
ok mai soll dann drei monate
vakuum im weltraum standgehalten haben wo sind die lyme spuren was kostenlos chef franco sie entschließt schlamperei nicht aus aber eben auch
zitat eine andere version die wir nicht ausschließen
eine absichtliche störung im weltall
auch rogosin hat mehrere versuche festgestellt ein loch in die sojus kapsel zu bohren sie seien mit
zögerlicher hand ausgeführt worden das ist wirklich keine gute situation und spricht eigentlich alles dafür
dass das loch dort oben gebohrt wurde was ist da oben also gerade los wie soll der täter gefunden werden was sind die konsequenzen
muss das sojus programm eingestellt werden wird die space extraction
krug apfel jetzt schneller zum einsatz kommen so etwas ist wirklich eine absolute katastrophe und wenn es sich
bewahrheitet das erste mal überhaupt dass im weltall sabotiert wurde wir halten euch hier auf dem laufenden
wenn ihr kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann abonniert klick so
genau die glocke nicht vergessen dafür klicken folgt mir auf whatsapp da gibt es die videos früher da stehe ich euch vorher
nachricht dafür hier klicken keine werbung mehr auf clips um gibt es wenn ihr mitglied werdet der linkes unter dem video
wir danken schon mal für diese unterstützung und
wenn der link dann nicht es war am computer anschauen und hier geht es weiter mit der wettlauf ins weltall bis dann
bleibt dran